today I'm being set on fire
three two so in the first stuntmen react
video Eric just briefly mentioned as a
side thought hey we should light you on
fire
you should light him on fire sometime oh
yeah I'm down two weeks later when the
video came out he sent me a text so when
are we letting go on fire
my honest first thought was absolutely
let's go let's do it that sounds like
the best I'm so down I thought about it
you know I have a mom I have a dad and
you know before I typed never I actually
thought it would be really cool to show
you guys how stuntman pull off one of
the most daring and dangerous stunts in
Hollywood movies using my body as
tribute to this whole thing so yeah we
have Eric here today he let me on fire
with this crew and it's a great I have
no idea what to expect other than the
fact that I will be lit on fire at some
point today yo is it true that I have to
like eat ice cubes before I get
something firing yeah have to yeah ok ok
hey Eric yeah absolutely
for real dude I was like they eat so
much ice what's up guys I am with Eric
lended and Oman's aider these are
Hollywood professional stunt man stunt
coordinators so this is your your team
we're gonna we're here to keep you safe
there's a lot of different videos out
there that talk about this process but I
think what's really cool is we're gonna
step a guy who hasn't done it through
this process and keep him safe there are
a lot of things involved to keep someone
safe especially sending someone on fire
that's never been on fire I love that
seeing people's first reactions and just
the property the fire and they learn the
basics of fire how fire always moves up
you want to keep it behind you away from
your face one of the safest ways is what
we're gonna be doing today we're all
professionals we've been brought up
through the ranks and have learned trial
through fire that we just want to
educate you guys on what happens don't
do this it's a really bad idea
people's first question always is what
does it feel like well generally like
nothing
you're just freezing as eric has
mentioned in previous videos it's the
rest of the adrenaline the gel it
shouldn't feel like anything because as
soon as you feel any kind of heat well
you're kind of in trouble but it's fun
if it's done correctly with the right
team you guys
the right thing yes sir yeah all right
so yeah you guys so ideally what we want
to do we want to light your arm on fire
okay then we like to let your legs on
fire perfect okay and then we like to
light both arms both legs and you're
back on fire when you're setting
somebody on fire you got a protector
through the fire gel but you can't just
put fire gel on you know then you're
putting fuel on to the fire gel which is
what actually catches on fire yeah it's
a it's not the fire gel itself the fire
gel is just strictly like a barrier to
protect you against the fire now some of
the things that we're gonna help the
fire gel out with are these different
layers of fire protective clothing
there's many different kinds there's
there's no mechs there's fire resistant
cotton there's something called carbon
acts all of it kind of has its own
specific uses ultimately what we're
gonna do for this one is we're gonna use
this cotton layer two shirts for you
yeah okay
this layer is called pbi this is
actually fireproof well it does not
light on fire well normal that's the
weird part that's crazy
everybody's gonna say well what if you
put it in lava does this burn at some
point yes it will but by that point your
eyeballs melt out of your head okay
sweet so we don't have to worry about
that we'll never get to those type of
temperatures we are gonna be lighting
you on fire with the coldest possible
fire that makes it that makes sense to
me keep it as safe as possible right now
the other component to this is going to
be fire gel there's many different kinds
of fire gel we have action factories
don't gel today this is some of the best
stuff in the business so that's what
we're gonna use cool if you say it's all
essentially organic can I eat this yeah
wait really
Eddie like it's kind of fresh actually
fresh nice it's like a honey honey mint
I like that that's nice so what we'll do
is we're gonna take this and completely
cover the clothes with it right on our
left arm which one right ways left arm
just in case you're probably gonna get
cold it kind of draws the heat out of
your body okay and then eventually we'll
put it all over your head and all over
everything to keep you safe okay and
then we will put that wardrobe over top
of you so you have three layers of
clothing they are all covered in fire
gel then another layer of clothing that
will be burned I'm excited to be honest
thank you is it it's a nervous
excitement you know as you can see this
is a time-consuming process typically
when we're doing this on set we need
about a 45 minute heads up once our guy
is completely ready in an ideal
situation we walk him straight to set
and light him on fire like there's not a
lot of downtime what will happen is if
you wait too long the gel I have up here
will start sliding down his arm and
we'll pull up down here and I'll also do
that in his legs he'll still have some
gel but like the ideal system all over
his body starts to break down over time
so you don't want him sitting there for
three hours waiting to be settling on
five I'm feeling like an extra like 10
12 pounds wait until your little body's
going I know just like 40 pounds heavier
feel like a ketchup packet
pull this out like that okay so is it go
ahead and pass up test the guys bourbon
yeah we're good just for the size of
this burn more than likely it'll either
a burn out or B we'll just throw a
little wet rag on it cuz this is very
small if anything happens to go wrong
just let me in the team handle it
everybody just kind of step back we will
take care of it make sure clean feels
good do I need to stop drop and roll at
any point you do no okay we will get you
okay cool sauce and so we're gonna put a
little bit of fuel this is what burns
awesome all a little bit for now Mel's
like hot glue he said I think so
I'm on fire good day
I feel feel pretty good just looking at
some fire my right now so warm at all
not yet so let me know if start still
long okay so could I cook us more over
this you think it'd be positive nice
dude
is it getting warm at all yeah a little
bit a little bit so that's just
dissipated it's gonna warm up its fire
is the thing that we want to avoid
especially when we're doing a bigger
burn with you is it getting hot you need
to let us know when you are getting warm
so we can put you out even once the fire
is out if it remains hot the very heat
of it could give you a burn on your skin
even though the fire is completely gone
I'd literally be cooked yes my bean you
cooked a lot have you cooked okay cool
man so I don't want to like completely
engulf you in flames yet once it starts
to get around your face and everything
it gets to be a completely different
deal if you're comfortable with it what
I'd like to do is completely prep your
whole body okay and light your legs on
fire okay let's let my legs on fire cuz
I don't know if I'm ready for the full
body yet like on it honestly I'm like
I'm cool with that but my whole body
like both my arms my legs and my back do
look and if that's something that you're
not ready for no pressure
ready yeah let's do it
I get down to the tones you get all the
girls
yeah tuition like a big for firstborn
you gotta take a big scoop of this and
put it on your your crotch because I'm
not doing it but you guys I
oh my oh yeah just put it inside doesn't
so I don't want you serious you're no
104 series I think of a third time gotta
get two of you and windows God dang it
why just that part by the way that was
completely unnecessary it was just a
message this is smelled nice and fresh
this is what I'll be for Halloween dude
man I've been to the airport dude I've
been the TSA before has it been my for
TSA agents at the same time no that
would be a first
yeah dude yes
[Music]
ie breath you got in through the nose
out the nose I really do feel like a
salamander snapping pics then great all
right
okay let's chances are if you're
watching this video you like moviemaking
and chances are to watch a channel
you're probably into visual effects now
when you're doing visual effects usually
need two elements to add your footage
explosions blood splatters sparks that
kind of stuff the thing is when you have
to go and buy a pack of like 20 blood
hits just to use the couple it's kind of
expensive so we've teamed up with action
V effects to curate what we call the
battle box it's a collection of all the
elements you need to do a cool action
scene at an affordable price we've taken
the best from each pack couple
explosions a couple blood splatters a
couple muzzle flashes and sparks all the
good stuff and action the effects man
they just knock it out of the park with
their elements they're such high quality
elements its corridor digital calm slash
battle boxes I'll link in the
description below I think you'll enjoy
it if you're trying to get individual
effects yourself let's go Mike Clint on
fire
every stop talking now overall focused
he's just quiet work just like incense
clint's concentration he's breathing
through his nose so harder now
he's trying not to sugar and be cold I
wonder if he's regretting it now but
either way it's too I turn back it's
only one way to warm them up we've
layered him up with all the layers Reid
gelled as we put each layer on make sure
it's nice and thick and this rubber suit
is like not necessary for this one but
we're doing anyway just kind of help
show the process the suit essentially
keeps the gel in I feel like a garbage
man already like a space garbage man
that's Steve it's Steve did you do you
know we're doing right now just you did
like pick up some guns okay put these
out so that place to park I'm a
considerate landlord I am NOT just any
landlord
Who am I I am Lord clearly in about ten
minutes
Clint is going to do his first full body
burn where is he going to do this by the
way wait a minute dude seriously
oh you're covering that we'll make sure
the scorch marks are cleared away and I
did it about 30 years ago and I had to
put this gel on me and I did on fire
while on fire jumping jacks and it
looked great god this is great you know
when you're like trying to run but you
can't yeah a fight but you can't that's
how I feel right now dude I feel like
frickin Chum though what we're gonna do
is we're gonna fuel both of your legs
yeah and then we're going to go ahead
and light that on fire okay as you start
to feel like it's warm I want you to go
ahead and call it oh there's not a whole
lot of wind in here but once we get out
there it's gonna be a little bit
different okay cool okay everybody set
do it kind of move around a little bit I
always liked you
[Music]
yeah yes Joe yes people show go ahead
and stand back up like it feels nice I
that can feel some warmth the slightest
warmth in my legs and that's very nice
for now because I am pretty cold what
I'd like to do next in the next stage of
all this is we'll prep your head yeah
this is awesome there's a moment yeah
I'm not gonna forget this forget Eric
brother gel all over my chin dude I
can't hear I'd like to light up another
one arm okay but we'll do it much bigger
yeah and I would like you to kind of
move around and feel the fire a little
bit okay you good with that
yeah I'm good with that
don't move around love it
[Music]
well
yeah see the wind feelin it
hotspots good
anything good good okay good right now
the real question is do you want to do a
big like more fire or an or five do you
want to do all of them
I mean we're I didn't get suited up for
nothing dude yeah
so we're doing yeah we're doing it yeah
we're good I'm gonna touch up your face
make sure that this is completely
coverage everywhere and then we're gonna
we're gonna go for it so what we'll do
is I'll fuel you up nice and big let's
just dudes once it's just one time yeah
yeah I want you to hold your breath the
entire time okay and you will run a jog
speed right down to there and then when
you get to the blanket me down and out
like a superhero yes it just landed yes
like all cool okay yeah yeah I can do
that and we'll put you out this is the
moment of truth we've brought to you and
prepared you I'm ready man to say I'm
ready
ready three two
[Music]
does anything hurt are they good good
I've gotta stand up maybe just like
right here great I have no I got feel
good right now oh wow grab fire man
that's the whole bag
that's everything what a fire inspectors
dream the real question here is we're
asking need another one one do one more
some sort of variation I will light you
up and say action and you kind of do a
turn a little bit of the chicken dance
and then go at any point even if you
only make it three steps if you want out
go down okay all right let's go ahead
three two one
[Music]
hotspots goodgoodgood
water bottles great thanks to you oh
really good thank you good job boys
how's your nose you've been a safe
keeping a real man those it's great
everything's good
yeah killed it man all these people came
out to see you burn I guess that's how
it is huh
[Music]
this spin is great man well I think I
feel like Clint's got a profile Cougars
are one yeah there it is dude thank you
so much for dude okay have an amazing
experiences yeah freakin sweet dude it
was exhilarating yeah I felt like I
loved being in the zone and I love it
when it comes down to like super focused
I love those moments and that was
definitely one of those moments for me I
felt like I could a jog like three to
four times that distance but who knows
maybe there's like a spike like right
after I did double that distance there's
just like I am I'm on fire and I'm
actually burning I had I don't know I
don't want to push the limits you know
but I felt good like I don't feel like
I'm on fire I don't feel like I'm
burning right now I feel great work of
art that's what I call it a work of art
and it went in you got two good takes
and Clint is doing great and he's
wonderful
he has no PTSD that I can see he's a
happy guy yeah yeah it's a very unique
art form it's just really cool to see
you demonstrate it for us here this was
not to show you guys how to do this or
how to light yourselves on fire that's
absolutely not what we wanted we wanted
to show you how to keep somebody safe
and just what how much work goes into it
and how much knowledge you need to have
to be able to light somebody on fire and
get them out of it safely completely
unscathed yeah so thank you so much for
having us
and please do not try this at home by
this point you guys got me nowit but you
can follow Erik when didn't have
his website but seriously a big thank
you to you in the whole team for coming
out here and helping us with this
because I just hope that we continue to
like deepen people's respect and
understanding to the craft absolutely
successful stunts nobody got hurt it's
Miller time so if you want to light
yourself on fire but you don't have a
Hollywood stunt team chances are you
going to need visual effects we're gonna
get that fire from you ask through your
computer to me and I hear you there you
get the battle box it's a collection of
all of our favorite elements through
action the effects everything we use
from explosions to muzzle flashes to
bullet hits all brought into one
affordable package for you we can click
the link in description below and you
can see each and every element so if
you're a visual effects artist just
signing out I already got a great
library I think you're gonna find this
very useful I almost forgot if you buy
anything else and action the effects you
can use a promo code corridor for 10%
off please consider subscribing guys
thank you for watching the video I think
Clint had the time of his life see you
the next one